this picture of a track and field
athlete has been going viral because she
looks like Brock Lesnar and guess what
it's actually his daughter and she's
been crushing it at Colorado State Maya
Lesnar just recently broke a women's
shot put School record with a mark of
18/2 M and that Mark currently leads the
nation right now it's pretty hard to
follow in the footsteps of a WWE legend
and maintain a level of greatness but
Maya has been nothing short of that and
has been doing it even before she broke
the record she earned all Mountain West
honors before placed first in the weight
throw at the indoor Mountain West
championships and finished in the top
three for both indoor and outdoor track
and field championships we may not know
if she'll ever become an all-time great
like her dad but so far Maya's off to a
great start in her young career